things have gotten super interesting in
the state of Utah there's a new poll
that was released yesterday by Emerson
College which shows that not Donald
Trump not Hillary Clinton not
libertarian Gary Johnson but rather
independent Mormon candidate Evan
McMullen is leading in Utah for the
presidential race the survey shows that
McMullen is at thirty-one percent
support Trump 27 Clinton 24 in the state
of Utah now the margin of error on this
poll was three-point-six percent
according to the methodology and uh it
also is just one poll in an average of
Utah polls McMullen is not in the lead
it is still Donald Trump in the lead so
we're just talking about one state we're
just talking about one poll but the
major Republican candidate not having
Utah as a complete and total foregone
conclusion of a gimme is major major
news the last time that a Republican
lost Utah was nineteen sixty four when
lyndon b johnson defeated barry
goldwater the last independent candidate
to win electoral votes was
segregationist George goal George
Wallace rather in 1968 so I don't agree
with voting for Evan McMullen Evan
McMullen does not represent my views but
I have to hand it to the Mormon
community they are really putting the
evangelical Christians to shame as I
discussed on the Monday bonus show
earlier this week there's this situation
when we look at different Christian
groups where evangelical support for
Donald Trump basically peaked in July at
about seventy eight percent and it has
declined somewhat since we're right now
about two-thirds of white evangelicals
say that they're still supporting Donald
Trump and by the way that's after the
video was released of him saying that
using his celebrity status to just grab
women in the [ __ ] is something that he
thinks is okay and you just sometimes
gotta do two-thirds of evangelical
Christian voters white evangelical
Christian voters still are supporting
Donald Trump
is nothing Christian about Donald
Trump's candidacy at all we've seen the
magazine funded by by Billy Graham say
that it's absolutely absurd to think
that any Christians would support Donald
Trump uh but regardless the evangelical
Christians are by and large still
supporting Trump however we have a
survey from this last week among you
tomm Mormons and only thirty-eight
percent say that they're supporting
Donald Trump a higher percentage saying
that they have an unfavorable view of
Donald Trump even more unfavorable than
that of Hillary Clinton who has her fair
share of unfavorability herself so this
is so fascinating in so many ways but
Mormon Utah Mormons by and large vote
red and it is fascinating that they are
just running away from Donald Trump to
the point at which we can say Utah is
not a gimme for the Republican nominee
and that should be without question in
any normal election in the end a Trump's
probably going to win Utah but it is
going to be way way closer than it has
been in a very long time part of that
just because the the vote is being
significantly split three or even four
ways because Gary Johnson actually is
quite popular in Utah but a lot of this
because Mormons are saying i don't see
why i would vote Trump he does not
represent my values and that's
absolutely true